[Music]
if you ever saw the tv show entourage on
hbo if you remember the character ari
well he was based on the real life ari
emmanuel the ceo and founder of wme
endeavor
ari is a hollywood agent and has been
for many years and he comes from a
pretty remarkable family
his one brother is rahm emanuel the
chief of staff to obama in the white
house who later became the mayor of
chicago and his other brother zeke is a
world renowned doctor and bioethicist
so we talked about what it's like to
come from such a remarkable family and
the unique pressures that come with it
and it's just fun to talk to ari
this
is a bit of optimism
[Music]
most people would expect if i have the
aria emmanuel on the podcast to talk
about the future of entertainment
but right that's not what i'm actually
interested
in okay the thing that i'm really
interested in
is
parenting
and not you as a dad
but you as a son
okay because you are one of three
brothers and your family
is ridiculous
your brother's a famous doctor one
brother
the other brother is a big maca in
politics
right and former mayor of chicago and
you
run one of the most influential
entertainment organizations in the world
what did your parents do
i wanna know
i can't really say except that my father
was always curious
always [ __ ] trends he when he was a
young doctor he went against the ama
about lead in the paint and kids and he
had been an immigrant and he had he had
just come to chicago and he's he's going
up against the ama my mom was a bit
of the jewish version of a tiger mom
right she would take us to
demonstrations
she would not care about what people
said
and they did a very good job of
showing us the world as opposed to
having us sit in a room they took us to
israel when israel was just forming
and
sent us to camp run around and
just let us be and have to adapt
and those little things that are hard to
quantify or say what the parenting is
i think
exposed us to
running your own path
not worrying what people think about you
using common sense and having very good
self-esteem who was stronger your mom or
your dad as an influence on that in the
house both both pretty strong you want
to know a funny story about my mom which
is classic my mom which is why i love
her to death
so i haven't seen her in a year year and
a half as
you know because of the covet situation
and i've gotten double vaccinated she's
gotten double this i'm gonna fly into
chicago so
plane is late
i get in
like 45 minutes late
and i called my mom and i said i'm gonna
be late and she goes well i'm
disappointed in you
i'm like
i go immediately to the being the 13
year old like what did i do wrong
and i'm like what she was pissed off you
know and that's my mom you know she you
you have to hit standards right and that
i think actually
pushed us
and then gave us the engine to push
ourselves post my mother it was at the
time about grades but then about
business and being very competitive and
i think with three boys
close in age i mean
rom and i are 16 months apart
rom's november you know they're they're
a little bit more than 16 months but we
we were competitive so that and then
they've kind of went over into kind of
our lives just
the the thing that i find so fascinating
is like there are families where parents
do stuff and one of the kids
like pops you know but the fact that all
three of you have gone on to do
remarkable things and be
leaders in your respective industries
i mean it's it's pretty unique
were you treated differently because
obviously you're different personalities
and your parents didn't treat you all
exactly the same i mean they did some of
this stuff you said your mom you sort of
pushed you to drive
israel dragged us to dentistry i mean
you did you did all that stuff together
and i'm sure it had a dramatic impact
i mean
a jewish mother you know every jewish
mother wants their kid to be a lawyer or
a doctor right you're neither well let
me just be very clear when i stuck to my
dad
and i had gotten into like i was gonna
come back to chicago
i had
done summers at the merc in chicago and
i was gonna go to business school at
night and work during the day at the
merck and i said to my dad no
i'm gonna go into the mail room of caa
and make 15 cents a mile i mean i i
think he he almost plots
right and he goes what they can't take
the piece of paper away from you for
those who are listening that's collapsed
yeah you know
and i said no dad i think this is
what i want to do and to his credit
he said go for it
and he was always that guy even though
he might not agree
yeah and question it if that's what you
wanted to do
that's what you did it reminds me like
our parents
for most of us
they're
completely involved in our lives from
the day we're born until if you leave
the house to go to college or move on to
do whatever at around 18 right
and they know everything about us up
until that age
and then i realized that when i left for
college i continued to mature i
continued to grow but my parents were
missing it all they'd get it for like a
week here or a weekend there when i
would come home different now i mean you
got parents face timing all day long i
know and i wonder what that does because
one of the things that i recognize about
me is i would be 20 something years old
30 something years old 40 something
years old
and they would still talk to me
as if i was 18
because that's where that's where the
capped out and it took a long time
for them to sort of adjust to that i'm
not that like you and your temper simon
is like i haven't had a temper in a very
i think since i was about 18. my son
noah
was 24 or 25 you know slapped me around
figuratively
we were talking about something and i
kind of like became the parent when he
was 16. he goes you're not doing that
and immediately i kind of got it i was
like you know i'm not going to do that
he wants to tell me certain things he
tells me what he wants to tell me i'm
going to ask if he doesn't want to
answer cool
it is what it is
and
i think my parents kind of like for sure
my dad did
he was just proud of me asked me a bunch
of questions
and he was good with it but yeah my son
noah kind of put me in my corner like i
don't know about three months ago we
were talking about something i and he
goes uh-uh you're not doing that it was
really it was actually good it kind of
you got to be their friend now you can't
be their father
um and you can beat your father when
they when they ask you to be you were
treating him like the 18 year old then
he was 20 something 16. yeah i'll tell
you a crazy story i just heard about a
kid his parents were so involved in his
life where helicopter parents you know
couldn't couldn't do anything without
mom and dad's help
and his parents weren't there to remind
him
to take his diabetes
medicine
and he died
because he forgot to take his meds
you know i mean i've heard stories of
kids who miss class because their
parents didn't call to wake them at what
point does a a loving well-intentioned
parent that's not a loving parent well
that's just it i mean it's like the
parents who are wrapped up in the
varsity blues scandal the argument was i
just want to do what's right for my kid
i'm tr like any parent i'm trying to do
the best for my kid but the problem is
there's a line
and at what point does a parent who
quote unquote cares about their kid
recognize that they're actually hurting
their kid by being overly involved let's
just be very clear you have now
okay
i i couldn't stand it when it happened i
can't stand it
you get the awards for losing
yeah oh you know here's the trophy
everybody should get trophy
i mean what the [ __ ] are we talking
about and then there was a college it's
father's day it's mother's day
my parents barely drew i don't even know
they definitely didn't take me on the
college tour like no way
right my brother zeke drove me when i
was on the east coast other than that i
took myself around
i'm not sure they they moved me into
college
to be candid i don't remember it i think
maybe they did
they didn't come to visit ever
no
what are we talking about
so what we're talking about here is
independence then at the end of the day
your parents and it's debatable you know
as you said some of the stuff that they
did
would is not
you know times have changed they could
not do today but the question is are we
teaching our kids independence and
learning independence you could argue
teaches you confidence
yes so what's exciting you these days
well you know i'm learning a ton about
being a public company how's that and
what's exciting for me is thinking about
where the world's going and what we
should be doing in it i think we're a
unique company in all the positive
things about what that means about being
unique and i think we're ahead of the
curve and
making sure that we stay ahead of curve
and the culture kind of breeds that
is not easy when you're a public company
i know all my you know partners that own
stock are looking at the stock and
you know it's
it's it's actually complicated it's
harder to take a long-term view on the
company isn't it i mean because the the
ceos that i admire
of public company yeah
they take a long-term view and they say
buy us or don't buy us this is what
we're doing yeah that is my mode yeah
that's how i'm operating
um
uh the business you know my favorite new
quote i was listening
to billie jean king yesterday on cnbc
she says in the in her book or whatever
she says pressure is a privilege it only
comes to those who earn it
and i love that quote because
you should be happy that there's
pressure on your life
and you've earned it and kind of enjoy
it and think about what that all means
and
and there's no straight line yeah to
success it's a wiggly
gobbley goop of stuff that gets you to
the top
and you've got to be willing to take the
body blows that's one of the things i
actually admire about you
i mean you said it before that you don't
care what other people think and your
parents raise you to not care what
people think and look it's a blessing
and a curse it's a double-edged sword oh
i care but i just don't i'm not gonna
let it like it affects me but i'm not
gonna let it affect me to that i'm not
going where i think is the right place
to go of course it affects everybody i'm
not i'm not a robot
but
if i have a point of view yeah and i
take a bunch of information and i and i
have a lot of trusted people
uh and i still have that point of view
after a bunch of you know all the
kind of i'm still going where i'm going
and it it's not comfortable yeah because
you have to you could be wrong
whatever that means wrong
so how do you teach your kids but also
how do you teach your those who work
with you on your team i sent that quote
out to the whole company yeah
right yeah hopefully i tell stories
about the pressure we had when we had to
make the ufc deal the pressure we had
when covet had the pressure we have and
how to kind of handle you just have by
example like my father did like my
mother did
here's how i'm operating
reiterate it reiterate it reiterate it
let them be in their present when they
ask you for help give them help
and
you know
let them know it's okay if you
don't hit the the objective i'm trying
to change my vocabulary
about failure not hit the objective i
don't believe in the word failure i mean
i've learned so much in the process of
making that decision that didn't work
out how i thought yeah
that whole learning curve enables me to
the next one so it's not a failure it's
just a learning process and in that
godly group of success yeah and if
people look at it that way
i think it's better i that's how i look
at it that i'm not sitting here failing
i i just didn't achieve
the outcome i want i think the word you
know this and it comes from tech you
know this idea of fail fast and accept
failure and fail off and all this and i
agree with you i think the problem with
word failure is it's like the word
cancer which is if you have a mild
melanoma
or you have stage four liver cancer we
call both those things cancer and the
problem is they are not the same thing
right and i think it's the same thing
with the word failure when most people
hear the word failure they think
catastrophic collapse
and then we come in and say fail f and
fail fast don't i mean you got to be
nuts and so i think what we need is a
new word to capture the thing that
people are talking about and i like to
use the word falling which is i reject
failure i do not want to fail but i fall
and i fall often and i judge myself by
how quickly i get up we all have to
figure out a new vocabulary here i just
don't think it's failure because i agree
i would say to you falling isn't scary
failing is scary scenario where i have
not achieved what i wanted yeah i have i
have fallen right it has it has enabled
me
to gain relationships
thought processes and then for the next
one get better what i'm learning about
you from this conversation which i
really love is that you have a very long
point of view and you said of course it
affects you you know what people think
about you of course but it's your
ability to stay focused beyond the
horizon
that allows you to stay on the path as
opposed to
be pushed and swayed
by
the opinions of those around you who who
would push and sway the rest of us
well i i don't have twitter i don't have
instagram i do a lot of reading i'm very
curious as it relates to that i talk to
a ton of people i constantly am asking
opinion about stuff and where the
world's going and how to think about i i
organize myself in with a lot of
different voices around me so i can get
true objective feedback
and then
iterate
as i go forward
do you have a vision
that exists for the future that is not
related to the company you know you know
as i said my brother he wants to die at
75
right
i want to i want to die
even though this is has ethical
ramifications to the world
never
oh god how fasari
i enjoy my life i'm having fun i mean
who i have a blessed yeah
blessed life but that's you
how will the world be a better place
what do you imagine
when
one day if it ever happens
your time comes and you can lie on your
deathbed at 496 years old
and say you know what
that was worth it it was worth it
already you know i freaked out three
months before 60.
and then when 260 came i was like like
what were you freaking out about i don't
have to race to anything right now i've
come to the conclusion that
you know when you're dyslexic and i'm
severely dyslexic severely just like i'm
not as dyslexic anymore you know because
i've worked very very very hard at it
you always think somebody's going to
pull
the blanket off and say you're an idiot
you're not smart i'm actually
comfortable that you know my ideas are
pretty interesting i can organize people
for whatever reason i've achieved a lot
yeah and i'm not done i'm not even close
for my own internal engine right the
engine is kind of revving constantly is
there an end point in mind no
one thing i am going to do i want to
build a school for kids that mike all
three of my boys were dyslexic and they
got the privilege of going to a school
that specialized for people with
dyslexia and other things i do want to
build that
and start that because if you think
about kids that have dyslexia there's
two paths they're either very athletic
of the arts creative business competent
or
they end up in jail i mean there's not a
lot and i think
there's a bunch of kids that haven't
gotten the privileges that my kids have
gotten that deserve it because a real
you know dyslexia is not that you're not
intelligent it has actually zero to do
with that actually i'm a great believer
that the solutions we find to the
challenges we have when we're kids
become our strengths as adults yeah i
also have adhd and when i was a kid it
wasn't a diagnosable thing i just had no
attention span and got yelled at for not
finishing my homework and not reading
the books and whatever how do you read
books now i i actually don't read a lot
of books the joke i make is i've written
more books than i've ever read
and i said and i've been saying that
since i wrote start with why
i love the idea of books because i love
learning and i'm insatiably curious and
so i buy books
and i start all of them and i get
distracted and then i just they get put
down and it really upsets me and i
learned this as a kid because i couldn't
get through school because i didn't do
the reading ever
and so i had to learn
to ask questions and listen i had to i
had to go to class and when i got to
college i couldn't take the classes
where you could just go study the text
skip class and come and take the test i
had to have good professors and i since
high school would always go after class
and talk to the teacher
just to learn
and so that was your process that's my
process and so to this day
my learning comes from calling the
people and this has been forever just
meeting people and talking to people who
are doing interesting things and then i
can put together
yeah the podcast is much more for me
than it is for you
and it's true every podcast i've done
i'm actually learning what advantages do
you have because of your dyslexia i
think uh you know that whole phrase
perfect does not lead to progress
i think
that i trust people to do their job so
my head's a department i trust them
i trust uh other people that you know
i'm involved in picking that they're
doing their jobs and i understand that a
lot of them are not gonna get it all the
way to where i would have gotten it but
again
if you're just gonna go forward just
based on
perfection
i would have been for people
1995 and not moved forward but that
doesn't answer the question what
advantage you have well it enables me to
build teams when you're dyslexic you
need a lot of help from a lot of
different people when you're young and
therefore you have to put a lot of
people's lives
get to the next level and then when you
move to business you have to put a lot
of people in your lives to get to the
next level and trusting that other
people can do stuff
that it doesn't only lead to you to do
it and i say this to a lot of my
associates who don't
share i would say or that haven't shared
in the past why wouldn't you let that
guy in new york do that what are you
doing i'm showing you that i'm giving
clients to other people
letting people do certain things that
are better at better than me at doing
them and you i got better grades because
of it i looked how i learned i learned
visually so how i built my life when i
was younger enabled me to build a team
that i trusted to go forward that
enabled me to go even farther i'm having
an insight here which is as a dyslexic
kid and a kid with adhd you had no
choice but to ask for help and rely on
other people
and build networks
and for me as a kid with adhd i had no
choice but to ask for help and rely on
other people
and i think one of the things that the
helicopter parents do
by removing the pressure
and by filling in the gaps
we disallow a child
to learn
to
ask for help and build a team to help
them get through
school and and work and through life and
so what we end up doing is is dropping
kids is dropping kids in life
and
they either lack the skill or lack the
actual network of people to lean on and
rely on and ask for help other than
their parents and so what they actually
have is loneliness and they feel like
they have to do it alone and the irony
is
you and i consider ourselves independent
and the the irony is is we actually rely
on people more
whereas kids who actually are
independent actually become incredibly
dependent yes i think that's true that's
actually a very good conclusion and so
now it raises the great question and it
goes back to billie jean king
which is then what mechanisms do we as
parents or as leaders
have at our disposal
to help our
teams learn what we call independence
but in reality
is the confidence to ask for help you
know this is
i think go back to my father and my
mother you just have to let them be and
fail and
and by osmosis teach say certain things
you know i send out emails i send out
quotes i send out articles
creating these whole places where
hopefully by osmosis they're absorbing
what you're trying to get like hey
team build archit all the things that
you do as a leader whether how you
handle a client or how what you're
asking them to read or how you handle
yourself that is permitting them to say
it's okay for me to try and it's okay
for me to
make a misstep and get back up and learn
from that but i'll go back to what i
said a moment ago which is we do all
those things but the expectation is not
that they'll learn how to do it the
expectation is that they'll learn to ask
for help and build a network of people
around that's the actual expectation and
i just love this this irony that being
independent actually means the
confidence in oneself and one's ability
to ask for help to be confident that i'm
an idiot
and if i'm if i'm confident if i'm proud
of and confident that i'm an idiot then
i have no problem asking for help and
that actually helps me weather the
opinions and pressures put on me by
others because i'm okay
being the idiot and that they disagree
with me
whereas when we quote unquote teach our
kids independence it's actually the
opposite they only become dependent on
one group or one person their parents or
maybe not even that they have own
network of relationships to lean on to
ask questions about to ask for other
expertise and how they would have
handled how they handled because those
people also are in the same place that
they are with just one or two people at
the top of their lives this is so good
this is all right i gotta go i love you
i love you i'll talk to you soon bye bye
and that's it
he's gone
that's how ari ends phone calls
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself
take care of each other
you